Speaker 1: Can you walk me through what it was like searching for a flat in Delhi or any other big metro city that you have ever lived in, if you've lived in one before? What did the process feel like?
Speaker 2: It often feels there's fear because when I'm I usually look at flats and flatmates because I can't afford a broker even when I'm with a broker I can't tell them that I'm clear or something. So I have to like really tread a fine line. On flats and flatmates I often after the flat seems nice vagaira I'll tell the guy.
Speaker 2: Because usually I can only room with men.
Speaker 1: Hmm.
Speaker 2: So, I usually when I tell them, yeah, I'm gay, some of them just back off. Some of them are like, oh, cool, it's fine. And then I can look at other things. But there's always this fear of homophobia and then that will close some like great places. The process of looking for a flat has always been flats and flatmates.
Speaker 2: filtering through all the dealing with all the anxiety that comes with it and yeah eventually hoping to find a safe place as a man very male sits presenting and as a Hindu upper caste slash person.
Speaker 2: I have not faced any major hurdles, but when I was roaming with a friend of mine in Pune who was Muslim, tab we had plenty of problems of trying to find a place.
Speaker 2: He could not find a place for over like 2 months.
Speaker 1: And and why was that? Just because of his religion.
Speaker 2: Ya
Speaker 1: You probably have had to conceal or manage things about yourself in order to get a house, right? And and what what did that?
Speaker 1: feel like in that moment if you want to talk about it.
Speaker 2: Uh, there's a lot of anxiety around it.
Speaker 1: Mm-hmm.
Speaker 2: Uh, because in one way it's good because, uh, landlords are mostly worried about you bringing over girls. So what you ask is, uh, are, in fact, my friends come along sometimes and then they're mostly fine with that.
Speaker 2: But then you also have to be wary about.
Speaker 3: But they
Speaker 2: You're the pitch of your voice when you're talking, like if you're with a gay friend of yours, you can't be cackling because then that, you know, a signal. You can't play pop music. All of those things when you're doing, when you're trying to just live your life.
Speaker 2: You have to be wary of neighbors and things. The filtering, at this point I'm used to it almost because I do it in most other aspects of life, and yet...
Speaker 3: And.
Speaker 2: I just feel like playing the role of deepening my voice, changing my mannerisms when I'm with a broker or a landlord.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Speaker 2: Uh, just to put them at ease, like, because then it makes the whole process easier. Uh, when my friend, uh, who is also a gay man, was looking for a place in Delhi, he was finding it very hard to deal with landlords, so he would call me over because I find it easier to be masculine.
Speaker 1: Mm-hmm.
Speaker 2: And then the landlords would have an easier time talking about things with me.
Speaker 1: Is there any specific moment that stays with you if you want to talk about it, you know, maybe something a landlord or a broker or somebody from an RWA said or did, you know, that made
Speaker 2: Hello
Speaker 1: Housing discrimination explicit or impossible to ignore or ignited some kind of emotional responsibility.
Speaker 2: So the Muslim friend that I mentioned earlier, uh, because he couldn't find a place at all.
Speaker 2: Uh, I had, uh, in my flat, uh, there was a space available.
Speaker 1: Hmm.
Speaker 2: So I convinced my landlord to let him room there.
Speaker 2: And even then he was like so he was extremely hesitant about it. I reassured him 10000 times that this guy works at my company. He's from Satara, he's a good friend of mine, he's a nice person, this and that. After that he allowed him to stay there and he would pay his rent on time, he was not.
Speaker 2: a problematic tenant at all. And yet, there was one point when two of our female colleagues were over at our place and the landlord just burst in and he was like, what is happening here? This is not allowed.
Speaker 2: Uh, why are there women here? I have told you, uh, this guy must go, I mean my friend, uh, who is Muslim. So he was worried about Hindu girls being over at our place, uh, at the place of a Muslim man because of love jihad and the whole and then he started talking about terrorism and how Muslims are always terrorists, this and that.
Speaker 2: So it was textbook islamophobia and that shook me for a while. So, uh, my friend had to obviously look for a new place and then I also left the place eventually. Um, yeah, that was an incident that really, uh, it was, it was like straight from a movie script.
Speaker 1: And you were witnessing this incident, you were together, both of you at that point.
Speaker 2: Yes, yes. I was trying to calm him down. I was trying to explain him this and that, yeah, because I can do that and he cannot stand up for himself.
Speaker 1: Sandpur.
Speaker 1: And maybe, you know, you were able to stand up for yourself because you were concealing parts of your identity at that point, I guess.
Speaker 2: Yeah, of course, of course, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Speaker 1: Yeah, yeah, yeah. Had you been very open about it then I think.
Speaker 2: Then I would be the target.
Speaker 1: Then I would be the target. What compromises did you end up making, you know, in terms of the home itself, the neighborhood, or the version of yourself you could be in it?
Speaker 2: Hmm.
Speaker 2: The version of myself certainly, neighborhood I don't think I've had major problems with.
Speaker 1: Hmm.
Speaker 2: Because you already find a space by being math and straight enough.
Speaker 2: But, uh, you have to, then I couldn't, you know, I always had this fantasy of when I'll be living alone and when I'll be earning my own money.
Speaker 3: Hmm.
Speaker 2: I'll wear skirts, I'll wear saris, I'll dress the way I want to. I'll be androgynous or feminine, and I could not do any of those things because I was always concealing my identity from my landlord, right?
Speaker 1: Mm-hmm.
Speaker 2: And then from the neighbors as well. So it felt unsafe to walk out of the house in a skirt.
Speaker 1: Hmm.
Speaker 2: Uh, because then I could be thrown out the next day. So, um, it did impact the life, the idea of my life that I had for myself. I had to sacrifice that and I had to live as this.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Speaker 2: Extremely mass presenting person. The renters have rights.
Speaker 1: Hmm.
Speaker 2: But then in a real world scenario that really helps.
Speaker 2: Because then 5 uncles from the society show up with 10 men.
Speaker 1: Hmm.
Speaker 2: Uh, you don't really have any power there.
Speaker 1: Yeah
Speaker 2: Um, the police will not help you out as a queer person. I, I feel what can help you is...
Speaker 1: Hmm.
Speaker 2: having community because
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Speaker 2: Uh, there are organizations in Delhi or in other cities as well that have lawyers.
Speaker 1: Hmm.
Speaker 2: Uh, that can mobilize people and that can really help you out.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Speaker 2: So I think more than knowing about rights, having access to community is what will help.
Speaker 1: 14.
Speaker 2: Rentals in Delhi or another city.